this episode is brought to you by 99
designs the go-to graphic design
platform from vista that makes it easy
for you to find and work with amazing
designers online i have used them for a
long long time we'll come back to that
long time listeners of this podcast know
just how much attention i pay to details
a lot of details and how obsessively i
approach all elements of my work because
often the small things end up being the
big things whether it's your logo your
business cards even your email templates
think of my newsletters all these visual
elements tell your customers who you are
and what you're about so it's worth
sweating the details i've been using 99
designs for years now to ensure that
many of my creative projects whether big
or small are as cohesive professional
and beautiful as possible most recently
you may have noticed i've been working
with a designer at 99designs to create
distinct illustrations for my podcast
episodes you see them on instagram and
other places i've developed a great
relationship with the designer and i
intend to continue working with her for
a long long time from logos to websites
to packaging and books i've also used
99designs for
book designs and all sorts of
illustrations 99designs is the go-to
creative resource to build your brand on
any budget right now my listeners can
get 20 off plus a free 99 upgrade on
their first design contest a contest is
a great way to get started and find the
right designer for long-term work you
can also book a free design consultation
with a brand expert at 99designs.com
tim to receive personalized branding
advice over the phone their hands on
team has helped thousands of business
owners it's a great way to get the most
out of your experience with 99 designs
by vista head to 99designs.com
tim that's
99designs.com tim for your discount and
to sign up for design consultation today
this episode is brought to you by
athletic greens i get asked all the time
what i would take if i could only take
one supplement i've been asked this for
years the answer is invariably ag-1 by
athletic greens i view it as all-in-one
nutritional insurance so you can cover
your bases if you're traveling if you're
just busy if you're not sure if your
meals or where they should be it covers
your bases i've recommended it
since the four hour body which was god
eons ago 2010 and i did not get paid to
do so with approximately 75 vitamins
minerals and whole foods source
ingredients you'll be hard-pressed to
find a more nutrient-dense formula on
the market it has a multivitamin
multi-mineral greens complex probiotics
and prebiotics for gut health and
immunity formula digestive enzymes and
adaptogens
you get the idea it is very very
comprehensive and i do my best of course
to focus on nutrient-dense proper meals
but sometimes you're busy sometimes
you're traveling sometimes you just want
to make sure
that you are getting what you need ag-1
makes it easy to get a lot of nutrition
when whole foods aren't readily
available it's also nsf certified for
sport making it safe for competitive
athletes as what's on the label is in
the powder it's the ultimate all-in-one
nutritional supplement bundle in one
easy scoop right now athletic greens is
giving my audience a special offer on
top of their all-in-one formula which is
a free vitamin d supplement and five
free travel packs with your first
subscription purchase many of us are
deficient in vitamin d i found that true
for myself which is usually produced in
our bodies from sun exposure so adding a
vitamin d supplement to your daily
routine is a great option for additional
immune support support your immunity gut
health and energy by visiting
athleticgreens.com
tim you'll receive up to a year's supply
of vitamin d and five free travel packs
with your subscription again that's
athleticgreens.com
at this altitude i can run flat out for
a half mile before my hands start to
shake can i answer your personal
questions
[Music]
hello boys and girls ladies and germs
this is tim ferriss and welcome to
another episode of the tim ferriss show
my guest today is dr michio kaku you can
find him on twitter at michiokaku he is
a professor of theoretical physics at
the city college of new york co-founder
of stringfield theory and the author of
several widely acclaimed science books
including beyond einstein the future of
humanity the future of the mind
hyperspace physics of the future physics
of the impossible and his latest
bestseller the god equation subtitle the
quest for a theory of everything so we
will have no shortage of things to
discuss he is the science correspondent
for cbs this morning the host of the
radio programs science fantastic and
exploration and a host of several
science tv specials for the bbc and the
discovery and science channels we will
link to all of his social including
facebook instagram twitter in the show
notes but you can find it quite easily
at michiokaku in most cases and uh dr
kaku welcome to the show thank you for
taking the time yeah glad to be on
i thought i would start
by rolling the clock back to your
childhood and my understanding is you
did not come from
a wealthy family far from it but that
you certainly found time to build things
and i was wondering if there were any
notable examples or examples that come
to mind that you could share
with the audience
well you're right ever since i was a
child i knew that my parents were locked
up during world war ii
in a relocation camp in california
their assets were frozen
they were penniless when they were
released from jail
and just because they were you know
japanese americans even though they were
citizens they were both citizens of the
united states they were both born in
california for god's sake
so when i was a child
i realized that if i was to do anything
in this world i would have to do it
myself
so when i was eight years old something
happened which completely changed my
life
i still remember everyone was talking
about the fact that a great scientist
had just died
and on the evening paper all this showed
was a picture of his desk that's it
there's a picture of his desk with an
open book
and the caption said
the greatest scientist of our time could
not finish this book
well
i was fascinated by this story why
couldn't he finish it i mean he could
ask his mother right he could go to the
library i mean he could just look it up
what was so hard that a great scientist
could not finish that book
well i went to the library and over the
years i began to find out this man's
name was albert einstein
and that book
that book was to be the theory of
everything the god equation an equation
perhaps no more than one inch long that
would allow us to quote read the mind of
god
well i was hooked
i had to know what was this unified
field theory the theory of everything
that was supposed to summarize all the
laws of nature into
such a compact form
so when i was in high school i said to
myself this is it i want to be part of
this great search for the theory of
everything so i went to my mom and i
said mom
can i have permission to build an atom
smasher in the garage a 2.3 million
electron volt baited saw an electron
accelerator in the garage
she kind of stared at me
and said sure
why not and don't forget to take out the
garbage
well i took out the garbage and i got
400 pounds of transformer steel
22 miles of copper wire so much wire
that we had to wind it on the football
field in my high school
and the atoms manager consumed six
kilowatts of power all the energy that
my house had
finally it was ready i plugged it in i
heard this huge crackling sound of six
kilowatts of energy surged through my
capacitor bank and then i heard this pop
pop pop sound as i blew out all the
fuses in the house
and the whole house was plunged in
darkness
my poor mom you know she come home from
a hard day's work
and then she say to herself
why couldn't i have a son who plays
baseball
why can't he play basketball and for
god's sake why can't he find a nice
japanese girlfriend
why does he build these machines in the
garage
well yeah because of these machines i
went to the national science fair i won
the grand prize
and i met the physicists who built the
atomic bomb
i met edward teller father of the
hydrogen bomb
and he offered me a scholarship that if
i could get into harvard
he would fund it well i got into harvard
and yes
true to form he financed a scholarship
so i could go and fulfill my dream well
when i graduated from harvard
he offered me a job
a job at los alamos labs livermore labs
designing hydrogen warheads
but you see
i had a different scenario
you see
for me the hydrogen bomb was puny
it was not powerful enough
i wanted to work on the biggest
explosion in the universe
the big bang that is the god equation
set into motion the expansion of the
universe itself now that's for me
so i respectfully declined this very
generous offer but i said to myself i
want to work on the theory of everything
an equation no more than one inch long
that will allow us to summarize
all the laws of the universe into one
compact form i said to myself that's for
me
i must ask how did your patron this
person who paid your way through harvard
respond when you declined
his job offer
well he the war in vietnam was going
full blast
he knew that a lot of his young recruits
could not get a job because they were
going to go into the military and that's
what i did my draft board pretty much
told me that i would go to vietnam
and so i basically volunteered to go
into the military
hoping to be part of signal corps
that as i figured i could use some of my
physics education
in order to support telecommunication of
our troops
unfortunately they put me in infantry
i went to fort benning georgia where i
learned how to how to go through machine
gun fire i went to fort lewis washington
where i learned to fire machine guns in
fact i fired the entire united states
army's infantries a whole slew of
weapons fielded by the united states
infantry i i fired them all
so i said to myself yeah
i have to serve my country what can i do
was there a
conflict in your heart or mind having
seen how your
parents were treated in internment camps
in
serving
this country was there any
upset or any hesitation i'm just
wondering emotionally if there was
anything there
that's worth discussing not really
because i realized that what had
happened during the war
well let's face it the united states was
at war
and as a consequence in wartime people
do strange things
and however my parents attitude was that
well first of all we have to make sure
that it doesn't happen again
that if the war clouds start to rise
again we have to make sure that
that the locking up the huge sectors of
the population 100 000 japanese
americans were locked up
that it wouldn't happen again
but my parents also believed that you
shouldn't have a chip on your shoulder
you shouldn't hold it against the
country because the country was you know
very kind and generous made my education
possible and so you shouldn't hold a
grudge
and the thing to do is to contribute
contribute to society and that's what i
decided to do
to contribute to society not have a chip
on my shoulder
and do good
you've really in in some respects i mean
you've created many careers for yourself
but you've combined
technical skill
and
fluency with
communication and i want to focus for a
second on the technical side of things
because you mentioned that you asked
your mom if you could build an atom
smasher and i think there were a lot a
lot of people listening they wouldn't
immediately know what an atom smasher
is were your parents technical did they
have technical backgrounds no they
barely got out of grade school with an
education in
and as a consequence they
they didn't have a clue as to what i was
doing
they just knew that it sounded very
scientific and it sounded important and
so they said go for it
they were very encouraging they said go
for it
go as far as you can go
was there anything that sparked that
initial
curiosity in the sciences
well there was this mystery you know
curiosity is one of the great drivers of
human behavior
curiosity coupled with passion
those i think are the two great
ingredients that allow people to rise
above poverty and rise above hardship
curiosity and passion so i had a
curiosity i had to know what was in that
book now today of course i can read that
book i know exactly all the different
incorrect avenues that einstein was
looking at in a desperate search
which he failed ultimately to create a
theory of everything so curiosity is one
thing that drove me but also you have to
have a passion curiosity by itself is
not enough you have to be able to pay
your dues you have to be able to sit
down learn the math learn the physics
get up to a phd so that you can become a
professor
and so you have to have a passion that
takes you all the way to the top
i've read in preparation for this
conversation that you were fascinated
with isaac asimov's foundation trilogy
as a child i don't know if that's true
please fact check me if that's incorrect
did any particular sci-fi stand out
to you as impactful or
cultivating that passion and curiosity
well yes you see when i was eight years
old i wanted to be like einstein but on
saturday mornings i used to watch tv
and i used to watch flash gordon on tv
and once again i was hooked i mean
starships
rocket ships invisibility shields cities
underwater cities in the sky
what's there not to love with flash
gordon but then over the years i began
to realize that the two passions of my
life that is physics on one hand and the
future on the other were more or less
the same thing
that if you understood physics you
understood what is possible what is
plausible and what is simply impossible
so when i read science fiction i begin
to realize that if you have a background
in physics
you can sort of put things into place
you know when certain technologies are
going to go to fruition you know when
certain technologies will never happen
and it allows you to see into the future
so those are the two things that i do on
one hand i work on the unified field
theory the the god equation the theory
of everything but i'm also a futurist
that as i look to see what trends will
take us into the next five ten hundred
years thousand years into the future
and so watching flash gordon
really impressed upon me that if you
know physics you know the outlines of
the future not totally of course because
we make mistakes but you know what is
possible but it's possible and what is
impossible
i have many questions to follow up that
answer
and we're going to also veer into trends
and a few related questions and i'll ask
you about
physics of the future but first i wanted
to go back to harvard for a moment
and
to ask you if it's true that for a stint
at least you studied
philosophy and if so if you could
describe that experience
well i was very practical i knew that
you have to have plan b
if plan a doesn't work out what are you
going to do for plan b
you see for einstein and i studied his
life very carefully in fact even wrote a
biography of einstein
i realized that well he made enemies of
his faculty he would cut classes a lot
because he knew the material already he
was way ahead of everyone but he cut
class the professors hated that so he
got horrible letters of recommendation
so he had to go to plan b
which is become a menial worker he
applied for job selling life insurance
can you imagine opening the door one day
and there's albert einstein trying to
sell you life insurance
and he finally got a job as a low level
clerk at the platten office in burn
switzerland
from which he could launch the greatest
revolution of modern times relativity
which gives us the atomic bomb gives us
computer technology lasers gives us the
power of the sun in fact
and so he had plan b
and take a very a low level clerical job
well i had to have plan b too so i said
to myself why not learn computer
technology computers were just beginning
to surface
and stanford university was not too far
away when i grew up there it was all
apple orchards and alfalfa fields and
farm workers
but yeah stanford was slowly rising
and you can learn how to program
computers and so i said to myself that's
what i'm going to do for plan b
but i was also interested in philosophy
but i still remember a quote from
einstein and that philosophy he said is
sort of like honey
that at first it's delicious and tastes
great but then you realize there's
nothing really there
it's not going to show you the future
it just tastes good
and so he decided that well yes he will
learn philosophy
it'll guide him to a degree but it's not
going to pioneer new branches of science
philosophy is how you sort of like look
at the entire terrain of physics so yeah
einstein was a philosopher but he
realized he could not make a living
doing philosophy
now do you think that there are
certain branches of philosophy or types
of philosophical
questioning or thought exercises that
will become more practical in the sense
that for instance if we look at the
trolley problem
and autonomous cars sort of programming
machines
to behave in certain ways if they have
to choose between hitting say
four people in their 80s versus two
school children on the other side of the
road or something like that are there
types of philosophy or branches of
philosophy that one might view as more
practical or interesting than others at
least from your perspective there are
two areas of philosophy that i found
interesting one is epistemology that is
the theory of knowledge what is true
what is false and what is knowable
and that gives us unto the question of
god that is is god knowable can you
prove the existence of god so i was
fascinated by that question can you
prove or disprove the existence of god
and then he began to realize that there
are certain things outside of science
science is what is testable reproducible
and falsifiable but certain things are
beyond that that cannot be tested that
cannot be reproduced
for example the existence of god so i
think that a thousand years from now
people will still be debating whether or
not god exists because it's not a
provable statement like for example the
unicorn can you prove or disprove the
existence of unicorns and the answer is
no because if you say unicorns don't
exist maybe somewhere in a cave some
place where we've never explored before
there's a unicorn so it is impossible to
disprove
the non-existence of unicorns
and the same thing with god god is also
not a provable statement so a thousand
years from now we'll still be debating
the existence of god because there's no
proof no definitive proof one way or the
other
that can prove or disprove the existence
of god another example i was at a party
once where somebody came up to me and
said that she was cleopatra she was the
reincarnation of cleopatra
well i got into a conversation asked her
some simple questions about the history
of cleopatra and she got all the answers
wrong and i said to myself aha she's not
really cleopatra at all but then she
came back at me and left me floored
she said the history books
are wrong why do i know that because i
am the reincarnation of cleopatra you
can't believe the history books and i
was stumped
at that point i realized that that's a
statement that's not provable
therefore it is outside the boundary of
science
do angels exist well maybe maybe not but
it's outside the boundaries of what
science can test because if you say
there's no such thing as angels maybe
they just are in a place that you
haven't looked
so that was one area that i found
interesting epistemology the limits of
what is testable what is reproducible
and what is falsifiable
the other thing that was interesting to
me was the question of human thought
is it possible to build a robot
that can think like a human
and then i read about the work of alan
turing
the founder of artificial intelligence
theory the guy who helped to win world
war ii by breaking the german code
and sadly enough even though he was a
hero it was top secret because the
british had to keep code breaking secret
and he basically committed suicide for
the end of his life there was a police
raid and the founder of artificial
intelligence theory turned out to be gay
and he was put on trial he was forced to
take hormones
and he went crazy and he committed
suicide but anyway the point i'm raising
is
if you have a robot that acts like a
human talks like a human
then for all intents and purposes it is
indistinguishable from a human and
therefore is
a human
now that really set me into motion
because here was a very concrete test
that you could make
as to whether or not something is human
in other words if it looks like a duck
quacks like a duck
and waddles like a duck maybe it is a
duck maybe it is indistinguishable from
a duck if you hold that philosophy
then you come to the realization that
one day we will create humans out of the
laboratory
because it'll be asymptotically
indistinguishable
from a human now right now it's pretty
easy to tell that something is a robot
you ask it a simple question gets the
answer wrong so a bingo you know that
it's fake but one day
it'll be so close to us that it will be
indistinguishable from us in which case
maybe artificial intelligence is really
possible here's another example science
is getting to the point where we can
digitize
everything known about you
for example all of einstein's papers
lectures notes can be digitized and i
would love to talk to einstein i'd love
to sit down and talk to a robot that has
digitized all of einstein's memoirs and
videotapes and what have you everything
that's known
and so then that becomes at some point
indistinguishable
from einstein himself
and so in other words it may be possible
that the soul
the soul of a human might be digitized
because we're getting closer and closer
to creating things that are
indistinguishable from people in other
words this gives us digital immortality
you can live forever of course as a
computer program
but you can live forever because your
memories your personalities will allow
you to talk to your great great great
great grandkids
and your great great great grandkids
will be able to talk to you
because your computer program is
indistinguishable from who you are so
these are philosophical questions that i
think are actually quite interesting
how do you
think of burden of proof in the sense
that
while it may be impossible to prove
the non-existence of unicorns
the sort of
current expanse of human exploration has
have yet not turned up any unicorns so
in terms of of choosing what to
believe or not believe and i know some
scientists will say i believe in the
data right and that's their kind of
stock response
but reality seems to be at least in real
life messy around the corners how do you
think of burden of proof whether it's
say unicorns or something like
time travel
well first of all if you take a look at
detectives
are detectives scientists detectives
have data but you see scientists like to
create experiments they like to redo the
experiment many many many times so that
something is reproducible falsifiable
and testable on demand a detective is in
a situation where the crime has been
committed
you cannot recreate the crime you can
approximate the crime
but you cannot recreate the crime it's
not testable
may not be falsifiable but is it a
science
well then you have to realize that most
of physics is a detective story
that the big bang happened 13.8 billion
years ago it happened in the past it was
the crime
and so you begin to realize that all of
science is in some sense not testable
because you cannot recreate the big bang
you cannot uh test aspects of the big
bang you only have the remnants of what
happened after the big bang 13.8 billion
years ago and as a consequence you have
to be a little bit humble humble
realizing that there are limits to what
we can do in the laboratory because we
cannot recreate cosmic events like the
creation of the earth the creation of
the sun and the creation of the universe
but we do what we can
with the physics that we are given
now you mentioned something else what
was that again that
that pushed the boundaries of what we
can do
i guess the underlying question was just
around how you think of burden of proof
and the part of the reason that term
came to mind is and i know we're jumping
around and that's okay in an interview
from 2003 and scientific american you
had said
about 10 years ago i mean in 1993 if you
were a serious physicist talking about
time travel you'd be laughed out of the
scientific establishment so i wanted to
ask you what had happened post 1993 that
had made that
less the case and it seemed at least i
have a line here and please fact check
this you know originally the burden of
proof was on physicists to prove that
time travel was possible now the burden
of proof is on physicists to prove there
must be a law forbidding time travel and
i found that very interesting and i was
just wondering if you could kind of
expand on
how you think about wrapping one's head
around something like time travel and
whether it is possible or impossible
well it used to be of course uh that we
have a giggle factor in physics that if
you talk about higher dimensions you
talk about time travel most physicists
would simply giggle and
eyes would roll up in the heavens and
they'd shake their head
well they don't do that anymore
physicists like stephen hawking have
taken these things very seriously you
see after the war
einstein's roommate at the institute for
advanced study he had an office right
next to einstein kurt gerdel found the
first solution of einstein's equations
which allowed for time travel
time travel in other words if the
universe rotated if the universe rotated
and then you rotated around the universe
and came back
you could come back yesterday
you could come back before you left
which of course is time travel now
einstein of course was horrified by this
he said in his memoirs that we can
eliminate this possibility for physical
reasons i.e the universe expanded
the universe did not spin
if the universe spun
then time travel would become in place
well since then
we have found hundreds of solutions of
einstein's equations in which time
travel is a possibility
for example if i have a black hole or
something similar to a black hole a very
dense star and it rotates and it rotates
it does not collapse to a dot
it collapses to a ring
a ring and if you fall through the ring
you wind up in a parallel universe
these are legitimate solutions of
einstein's equations found in 1963 in
fact by mathematician roy kerr
and it means that we have to take it
seriously and then stephen hawking
jumped into the game
and he came up with the chronology
protection hypothesis
and that is there must be a law of
physics preventing time travel okay that
was a challenge he challenged the world
of physics to find the law that once and
for all would disprove the existence of
a time machine well what happened
nobody could find such a law and so
hawking was forced to admit that well
maybe time travel is possible because
there's no law preventing it well now we
have wormholes in fact string theory
which is what i do for a living is full
of wormholes you can't move in string
theory without bumping into a wormhole
someplace and a wormhole is the looking
glass of alice
alice stuck her hand through the looking
glass and her hand wound up on the other
end of forever in wonderland
well that looking glass is the black
hole a spinning black hole
collapses not to a dot but to a ring
that ring is the looking glass of alice
so that if you stick your hand through
the looking glass you wind up in another
parallel universe
and this gives us therefore a new way of
looking at the big bang
einstein said that the universe is a
bubble a bubble of some sort and it's
expanding that's called the big bang
theory
however string theory says there are
other bubbles out there in fact there's
a bubble bath a bubble bath of universes
and when these universes collide
well that gives you the big bang or when
these universes split in half that could
also be the big bang and so we realize
that there's a multiverse of universes
out there
some of which make time travel possible
now
at the next question that people often
ask me is if there's this bubble bath of
universes parallel universes then is
elvis presley still alive in one of
these parallel universes
and the answer is possibly yes
that if you are dead in one universe you
are not necessarily dead in a twin
universe
that people who have perished in one
universe may keep on living in another
universe now this sounds crazy right but
it goes by a name quantum physics
we physicists telling people that some
of their loved ones could still be alive
in another parallel universe
we tell them
get used to it this is called quantum
physics now of course to visit these
parallel universes would require
technology far beyond anything we can
muster so don't think you can visit
elvis anytime soon but it does mean that
well yeah these universes are possible
just a quick thanks to one of our
sponsors and we'll be right back to the
show this episode is brought to you by
wealthfront did you know if you missed
10 of the best performing days after the
2008 crisis you would have missed out on
50 percent five zero percent of your
returns don't miss out on the best days
in the market stay invested in a
long-term automated investment portfolio
wealthfront pioneered the automated
investing movement sometimes referred to
as robo advising and they currently
oversee 20 billion dollars of assets for
their clients
wealthfront can help you diversify your
portfolio minimize fees and lower your
taxes takes about three minutes to sign
up and then wealthfront will build you a
globally diversified portfolio of etfs
based on your risk appetite and manage
it for you at an incredibly low cost
wealthfront software constantly monitors
your portfolio day in and day out so you
don't have to they look for
opportunities to rebalance and tax loss
harvest to lower the amount of taxes you
pay on your investment gains their
newest service is called autopilot and
it can monitor any checking account for
excess cash to move into savings or an
investment account they've really
thought of a ton they've checked a lot
of boxes smart investing should not feel
like a roller coaster ride let the
professionals do the work for you go to
wealthfront.com
tim and open a wealthfront investment
account today and you'll get your first
five thousand dollars managed for free
for life that's wealthfront.comtim
wealthfront will automate your
investments for the long term and you
can get started today at wealthfront.com
tim
i want to
double click on time let's talk a bit
more about time and actually before we
get to time because that's
understandably pretty big subject
could you just define what you mean by
parallel universe
well take two sheets of paper and put
them side by side
so that they are parallel to each other
and then get a pencil and just stick a
pencil right through both sheets of
paper
that pencil is the wormhole it's a
gateway it's a gateway connecting two
separate universes and guess who came up
with this idea it was einstein himself
in 1935. in 1935 einstein was playing
with black holes mathematically of
course
and realized that if you took two black
holes and stuck them together back to
back if you fell into one funnel
you would go blasting out the other
funnel
so today we call them wormholes or in
this case white holes a black hole is
this ultimate vacuum cleaner everything
gets sucked into this vacuum cleaner
called the black hole but where does
that stuff go we're not sure but in one
theory is blowing out the other end as a
white hole
and so this white hole is connected to
the black hole through this gateway and
the gateway is a wormhole and this
gateway in turn may be a passageway to
another universe
a passageway to a distant point in your
same universe or perhaps even a gateway
into the past and so time travel can no
longer be totally ruled out it's
something that we physicists actually
study now
i'm
looking at the cover of one of my books
and the the cover is the order of time
by carlo rovelli
who is an italian physicist i think he
does a lot of work in quantum gravity
from recalling correctly and
in one of his presentations video
presentation i remember him holding two
different
hand watches one above his head and one
down by his waist and
saying something to the effect and i'm
paraphrasing here because i'm not
technical i don't have any physics jobs
but he said that effectively time
unfolds at different speeds
at these
different heights due to different
gravitational effects and so on
i'm curious if there are any statements
or characteristics of time that you can
can mention
that
might be
counterintuitive or
seem otherworldly to people who are
listening just because i think you're at
a better position than i am certainly
well most people think that time beats
at the same rate so that one hour on the
earth is one hour on the moon is one
hour in outer space but that's not true
it turns out that if you were in a
rocket ship orbiting the earth like in a
gps satellite
time can actually slow down a bit
or actually speed up depending upon how
fast you are moving so when you use your
cell phone to calculate where you are
located on the earth that cell phone has
to calculate einstein's theory the
general theory and the special theory of
relativity they calculate exactly what
time it is because it depends on how
fast you move in general the faster you
move the slower time beats
so twins one of our astronauts was a
twin went into outer space when the twin
came back most people assumed that they
were still the same age nope
the twin that went into outer space is
actually younger
slightly younger by a fraction of a
second than his twin on the earth
now on the moon time beats faster on the
moon so if i have a clock on the moon
it beats a little bit faster than a
clock on the planet earth a clock on
jupiter would be a little bit slower
than a clock on the earth and this is
not science fiction we measure this in
fact we use it for the gps system so
when a pentagon general fights a war
the war depends on einstein's theory of
general relativity and special
relativity or else the troops wind up
too late to fight that war because their
clocks are all wrong
so newton of course thought that time
was like an arrow
one second on the earth is one second on
the moon is one second throughout the
universe twelve o'clock is twelve
o'clock everywhere in the universe
einstein comes along and says not so
fast
time is a river
it's a river that can speed up and slow
down so that time beats faster on the
moon than it does on the earth
timing out of space on a rocket ship be
slower than time on the earth
a clock on jupiter be slower than a
clock on the earth and we measure it
that's why we have the gps system
and then we can even go one step beyond
that
the river of time can have whirlpools
whirlpools in the river of time and can
fork
fork into two rivers and that allows us
to resolve the time travel paradoxes
when you go backwards in time and meet
yourself as a child
and you kill yourself as a child
how can you survive as an adult when he
just committed suicide in the past
this is the grandfather paradox how can
you still be alive if you killed your
ancestors
well there's a way around it
and that is if the river of time forks
into two rivers
and in one river abraham lincoln was
assassinated at ford theater he died
but if the river of time forks
and you jump stream
and you're now on this other river
you can save abraham lincoln for being
assassinated at the ford theater but
you've saved somebody else's abraham
lincoln a parallel abraham lincoln
because the quantum theory allows for
parallel universes
now the quantum theory allows for
parallel electrons electrons can be two
places at the same time
and how do we use that in lasers that's
how lasers work that's how transistors
work anything quantum mechanical
is based on the simple idea that an
electron can be two places at the same
time now if electrons can do it why not
people
or for that matter why not the universe
so at this point you may say to yourself
this is weird well get used to it it's
called physics
and for those interested at least one
pair of twins
who
were studied extensively to my knowledge
scott kelly and his brother mark kelly i
had scott actually astronaut scott kelly
on on this podcast for people are
interested in in digging into that
further
i wanted to ask you next about
consciousness and your views of
consciousness because you could as you
mentioned have someone who
looks and quacks like a human let's just
say and passes the turing test
is convincingly human from the outside
looking
in effectively or looking at
how do you think about consciousness
yourself
if you do it all there are many ways of
thinking about consciousness let's take
a look at the human brain
there's something called the connectome
project
which is just as
earth-shaking as the genome project
the genome project of course sequenced
our genes and changed the face of
medicine you cannot go to the doctor's
office without at some point bumping
into an application of the genome
project it's changed everything
criminals can now be caught because of
the genome project well there's another
project out there just as powerful
it is called the connectome project
and it wants to map the human brain
every single cell
in a map of the entire human brain now
we've already mapped the brain of a
fruit fly believe it or not a fruit fly
has about a hundred thousand neurons
these hundred thousand neurons can be
sliced and diced and put on a computer
and we have a map a road map of every
single neuron
in the brain
of a fruit fly
and therefore in principle
if you were to replace every neuron with
a transistor
you could create a working model
of the brain
of an insect
now the next question is well what about
going up to a mouse
what about going up to a rat
and then going up to a rabbit
and then going up to a dog or a cat
well is it possible that we could slice
and dice their brain so that we would
have a road map of every single neuron
in the brain of a dog
well what's to prevent it i'm a
physicist and i realized that there is
nothing in the laws of physics
preventing us from creating a roadmap of
the brain of a dog
and if that's possible then why not the
brain of a human a human has a hundred
billion neurons in it
that's the number of stars in the milky
way galaxy a hundred billion
each neuron in turn is connected to ten
thousand other neurons to create this
vast jungle
of connections called the human brain
can we
have a map of the human brain
neuron for a neuron and the answer is
yes
when will it happen well let's be honest
it may take a hundred years for us to be
able to create the connectome project
but it is certainly possible
in which case it may be possible to
create a twin
a twin of the human brain neuron for
neuron that is identical to that of a
human
and then the big question is is it
conscious
well of course we can debate that
question till we're blue in the face but
like i said as alan turing the father of
artificial intelligence once said
that if it looks like a duck quacks like
a duck maybe it is indistinguishable
from a duck
so that could be digital consciousness
do you think that
it would be
i don't want to say as simple because of
course it wouldn't necessarily be simple
as recreating
this
neuron map or sort of
in some ways mechanical model
of the brain and then switching it on
and that that would in some
way create what we experience as
consciousness or could there be other
forces involved do you think there are
other forces or elements involved that
would make it more difficult than that
well actually i have a definition of
consciousness the problem with
consciousness is that everyone has their
own pet definition or no definition at
all
and we're basically debating ghosts
because there's no definition but you
see i have a definition of consciousness
that i laid out in my best seller the
future of the mind
because as a physicist we're you know
we're fascinated by the human brain
my definition of consciousness is
the sum total of all the feedback loops
necessary to create a model
a model of yourself in space and time in
society
so by that definition the simplest level
of consciousness is a thermostat
a thermostat has a feedback loop one
feedback loop and it creates a model of
itself in temperature
it regulates the temperature in a room
so i say that a thermostat has one unit
of consciousness
and then let's take a plant
let's take a plant in your backyard i
say that has maybe 10 units of
consciousness
is conscious of its temperature
moisture direction of the sun
oxygen
carbon dioxide content a few sensors
that give you maybe 10 feedback loops
and that is the consciousness
of a plant so i think that a plant is
also conscious but let's go up the scale
the next level of consciousness is a
reptile
a reptile has an understanding of space
but not much more it has to understand
where the food is located where its
potential mates are where its enemies
are so it has to be able to create
feedback loops that understand space
its location in space i call that level
one
level one consciousness is the thousands
of neurons necessary to create a
representation of space for a reptile
that's called the reptilian brain then
at the center of the brain because the
brain evolves from the back to the front
the back of the brain is the reptilian
brain the center of the brain evolves
later and that's the monkey brain the
limbic system and that governs
consciousness in society that is your
role in society who's top dog
who's the leader of the pack who's the
guy who's the fall guy in society
how do you defer to these people
consciousness of a social type you have
to understand your place in society just
like a reptile is consciousness decides
where it is physically located
then the big question is
what is human consciousness
what feedback loops does the human brain
give a human that differs from
monkeys
the fears from reptiles
that is the key question of which i have
an answer
the front part of your brain is what
distinguishes us from the animals and
what does that brain do
it creates a model of yourself
in time
it is a time machine
it daydreams it imagines worlds that
don't exist
let's do an experiment to test my theory
let's go to your dog tonight in your
house
and teach your dog the meaning of
tomorrow
such a simple concept
such a simple thing teach your dog the
meaning of tomorrow
well your dog understands space that's
the reptilian brain the back of your
brain your dog understands society that
is the society of dogs that's the center
of the brain
but the front of the brain the
prefrontal cortex is not well developed
in dogs
dogs do not daydream to the best of our
knowledge they have no understanding of
time other than where food is
because it was not necessary it was not
necessary for a dog to understand and
daydream
why does the dog have to daydream for
god's sake
and a bear it understands when to
hibernate but that's automatic is reflex
that governs the time behavior of most
animals now humans on the other hand
what do we do we constantly daydream
we can't help it we're constantly
imagining what am i going to do tomorrow
oh what am i going to do to meet sally
tomorrow where's the best path to go
it's constantly creating alternate
worlds
of consciousness so i say that there are
three levels of consciousness there is
location geometric consciousness
consciousness of space spatial
consciousness that is the reptile
then there is social consciousness of a
monkey
of a wolf in a wolf pack and then there
is temporal consciousness which is what
humans do and that is my definition of
human consciousness human consciousness
is the sum total of all feedback loops
of a human
assessing its place in time
essentially the future constantly
daydreaming about what can i do in the
future
thank you for that definition i'm very
happy you took the time to do that and
it can help prevent a lot of
disagreements if people first agree on
terms or definition of the terms because
it varies so tremendously and i'm going
to use that as a segue to the word god
but
i know another scientist whose basic
question for test of consciousness
although this is a much more elaborate
conversation is in effect are you aware
that you are aware so the point being
not that that that is useful or accurate
but that definitions can differ yeah
well i have a definition i have a
definition of self-awareness some people
say consciousness is self-awareness well
then what is self-awareness right what
is consciousness is your ability to
instigate all these feedback loops to
create a model a model of yourself in
space in society and in time and if you
think about it every thought every
thought that goes through your mind does
this
every thought in your mind is constantly
creating a picture of yourself in space
in time and in society in fact i tell
people if you want to disprove my theory
all you have to do
is create a chain of thinking that is
not part of the feedback loops that i
mentioned concerning space time and
society three levels of consciousness if
you can think of a thought
a thought that is outside the domain of
these three levels of consciousness then
you can disprove my theory
well i'm not going to attempt to do that
but i do want to ask you
about einstein since certainly you're
more qualified than i on all things
einstein
although i did take
mandarin language classes inside a
classroom where einstein wants taught
that's about as close as i get to
in any way being close and being
familiar with einstein the theory of
everything that he tried to accomplish
the quote that i have in front of me
is that it would allow him to quote read
the mind of god end quote what do you
think
einstein
might have meant or did mean by god in
this instance was it glimpsing the
source code of everything that would
allow you to have perfect predictive
powers what did he mean by reading the
mind of god well einstein wrote
prolifically about the question of god
in fact the god letter a letter that he
just dashed off one day years ago to a
friend about god it's sold for millions
of dollars shocked everyone because
everyone wanted to know what was
einstein's thoughts about god well
basically it's very simple he rejected
the idea of a personal god the god that
you pray to that gives you christmas
presents smites the philistines
he did not believe in a personal god
but he believed in the god of spinoza
that is the god of harmony elegance
beauty simplicity
the universe could have been ugly the
universe could have been random the
universe could have been chaotic but
it's not the universe is gorgeous the
universe is rather simple on a sheet of
paper you can write down the theory of
almost everything you can write down
einstein's equations and the quantum
standard model of hundreds of subatomic
particles is ugly as hell but hey it
works at low energies but on a sheet of
paper the low energy universe can be
summarized by one sheet of paper it
didn't have to be that way and so
einstein thought of himself as a young
child entering a library for the first
time this huge gigantic library and
here's this little boy marveling at all
these books and all he could do was open
the first book chapter 1 verse 1
and read the first page
and so einstein had a very definite
opinion about how
we as human beings live in an ordered
gorgeous simple world
and then galileo was also asked that
question
galileo said that the purpose of science
is to determine how the heavens go
that's the purpose of science the
purpose of religion is to determine how
to go to heaven
so in other words religion is about
ethics how to go to heaven
while science is about natural law how
the heavens go
so as long as you keep these two domains
separate they're actually complementary
there's no problem at all
the problem occurs when people in the
natural sciences begin to pontificate
about ethics
and when people who are religious begin
to pontificate about natural aloha
that's when we get into trouble
if you use that you've used it but i
don't know if you normally do in the
course of this conversation you've
mentioned the word god does that have a
personal meaning to you
well yes when i was a child
i realized that my parents were
buddhists
and in buddhism
the universe had no beginning no end
there's just timeless
nirvana that's the essence of one aspect
of buddhism
but they put me in sunday school a
presbyterian sunday school so i read the
bible i learned all the parables and all
the stories
and of course there is genesis chapter 1
verse 1 when the god sets the universe
into motion so the universe had a
beginning so i've had these two
contradictory ideas in my head either
the universe had a beginning or it
didn't no two ways around it right
wrong
now we can meld these two ideas into one
theory the multiverse theory you see our
universe had a beginning
our universe had a genesis it had a
moment of the big bang
but big bangs are happening all the time
because the big bang is a quantum event
meaning that it could happen again and
again and again
creating a bubble bath of universes
and so
the what is the universe expanding into
if we have this larger arena called the
bubble bath this empty arena is
hyperspace the hyperspace of string
theory so string theory allows you to
meld these two diametrically closed
theories
into one theory that our universe had a
beginning a big bang
but
in a multiverse we have a bubble bath a
bubble bath of universe is being born
all the time even as we speak that is
the essence of the quantum principle
if there's a probability of it happening
it could happen if you wait long enough
i know
nothing about string theory i'm
embarrassed to say fortunately we are
talking and so i feel like i can ask you
anything and everything about it
my layman's understanding is that string
theory is controversial is that an
accurate statement are there proponents
and detractors and controversy around
string theory or is that not the case oh
sure in fact that shows you how healthy
science is
that in science truth comes out of
incorrect debate with untruth and so
good thing we have controversies but
let's break down the controversies some
people say that the theory of everything
is not testable directly that is you
cannot create a laboratory that will
test the theory of everything
because string theory is a theory of
universes
every solution of string theory is a
universe and so to test this theory you
have to be god
to create a baby universe in a
laboratory that's a direct proof of
string theory well i think that misses
the whole point you see science is not
done directly most of science is done
indirectly how do we know that the sun
is made out of hydrogen
how do we know what's inside a dna
molecule
how do we know what's inside a proton i
mean we've never been to the sun
but how do we know these things because
we look for echoes echoes from the sun
called sunlight we look for echoes from
life called dna
so in other words we have indirect proof
of these things and in my book the god
equation i give five
five indirect proofs of string theory
the first indirect proof is
well it happened just a month ago
outside chicago
at fermi laboratory outside chicago they
found a crack
the first crack in the standard model of
particles
as i mentioned the standard model is an
ugly theory but it works at low energies
you cannot deny that the universe obeys
the laws of the standard model the
quantum theory but eventually it must
fail because a theory is so ugly that
only a mother could love it it has 36
quarks and antiquarks three identical
generations of particles 20 free
parameters that you can adjust any way
you want is horrible but it works
so we found the first crack meaning that
there's a fifth force out there beyond
gravity beyond the nuclear force a fifth
force out there which could be
the next octave of a vibrating string
string theory may give you the next
theory beyond the standard model next
lisa is a satellite that the european
space agency is funding which will give
us baby pictures
baby pictures of the infant universe
it's a gravity wave detector in outer
space that'll pick up gravity waves from
the instant of creation giving us baby
pictures baby pictures of the infant
universe as is coming out of the womb
and maybe just maybe we'll find evidence
of an umbilical cord
an umbilical cord connecting our infant
universe as it emerges from the womb to
apparent universe
in the multiverse
of universes that's well within the
cards as the european space agency and
nasa launch lisa into orbit in the
coming years
next
we have dark matter what is the universe
made of well atoms right wrong most of
the universe is not made of atoms most
of the universe is made out of dark
matter and we're clueless
clueless to understand what is dark
matter it holds the galaxy together it's
invisible that's why it's so hard to
prove
but no one's been able to determine what
it is
string theory predicts what dark matter
is it again is the next octave the next
octave of the vibrating string is dark
matter which makes up most of the
invisible universe
then next the japanese the chinese and
the europeans are laying the groundwork
for the next generation of atom smashers
much bigger than the one that i built
when i was in high school
and we hope to find evidence of the
fifth force by creating particles that
are only seen beyond the standard model
and then the fifth testable way to prove
the theory is to look for deviations
from newton's laws of gravity
newton's laws is based on the idea of
the inverse square law
if you double the distance away from a
star gravity goes down by a factor of
four
but why four why not eight why not
sixteen because we live in a
three-dimensional world the world is
three-dimensional but string theory says
nope
the world is 11-dimensional and we are a
three-dimensional bubble
a three-dimensional bubble floating in a
much larger 11-dimensional nirvana
so what is nirvana nirvana is
11-dimensional hyperspace
and what is our universe a bubble a
three-dimensional bubble floating in
nirvana which is expanding and that's
called the big bang theory
anyway so we're looking for deviations
from newton's laws of gravity which
could then clinch the existence of these
higher dimensions so these are five
experimental ways that we can test
string theory so let's say
flashing forward
that the god equation
is
i don't know if the correct term would
be solved for but that we arrive at
the answer the quest for a theory of
everything comes to an end what are the
possible applications because i'm sure
there are people listening just to step
into their shoes who are saying this is
incredibly fascinating i could listen to
this and explore this
for many many more hours but i'm worried
that in 20 or 30 or 50 years due to
climate change we will not have the
luxury of pursuing these types of
questions
what are some of the applications what
are the the outcomes
well some of the greatest philosophical
questions of all time
what happened before creation is time
travel possible cannot be answered using
the standard model
einstein's equations break down at the
instant of the big bang at the center of
a black hole all the interesting
questions well they break down
at the point where string theory starts
this is called the plunk energy
10 to the 19 billion electron volts
that's the energy of the big bang
and einstein's equations fail at that
point
that's where string theory comes in for
example what happened before the big
bang
if string theory is correct and there's
a multiverse we now can say what
happened before the big bang the big
bang was the collision or the splitting
of universes and we hope to get pictures
pictures verifying this picture
with lisa a satellite to be launched
into outer space
with funding from the european space
agency and from nasa and so that's one
application is to define what happened
before creation
is there really a multiverse and what's
on the other side of a black hole
well most theories say that a black hole
is a dot a dot of infinite density
anything falling into this dot will die
but that's the old picture we don't
believe in that anymore because these
black holes are all spinning spinning
rapidly and a spinning black hole
collapses to a ring
not a dot at all but a ring and if you
fall through the ring
you wind up in alice's looking glass the
ring is a wormhole but are wormholes
stable if you watch star trek you
realize that one of the problems with
wormholes is that sometimes they
collapse on you
so you're halfway through the wormhole
and whoops it collapses on you and cuts
you in half well the stability of
wormholes can be calculated with string
theory string theory is a theory of
everything including wormholes and we
should be able to calculate the
stability of these wormholes and then
time travel is time travel possible well
as i mentioned einstein's equations do
allow for time travel but how stable are
they that is when you enter the time
machine will it blow up hawking thought
so hawking redid the calculation showed
that time travel is possible in
einstein's equations but and this is a
huge but as soon as you enter the time
machine it blows up
well it blows up because again of
quantum corrections but string theory
allows you to calculate these quantum
corrections not speculate about them he
speculated that they are infinite but
maybe they're finite in which case you
can go backwards in time and visit
yourself as a child
and then perhaps the greatest
application of all
is the fact that the universe is dying
physics is the ultimate death warrant
for our universe
physics says the law of thermodynamics
says the second law
says that in a closed system everything
must eventually rust decay fall apart
and die
in other words trillions of years from
now the universe will consist of dead
black holes dead neutron stars and the
temperature will be near absolute zero
and will all freeze to death
this is called the big freeze
and it seems that the laws of physics
are a death warrant for the universe but
you see there's a loophole here
in a closed system the universe must die
but you see maybe the universe is not a
closed system maybe there are wormholes
which means that the universe is an open
system
and the second law of thermodynamics
does not apply for open systems and so
what do we do
trillions of years from now will be so
advanced that we'll be able to play with
the planck energy create wormholes to
order and create a lifeboat
an interdimensional lifeboat that we can
flee into
and go to another younger warmer
universe
and start all over again
in which case we'll have yet another
universe to mess up we've already messed
up this universe so we'll have yet
another universe to mess up we'll have
two universes to mess up complements of
string theory
you've mentioned the phrase you know the
next octave and terminology that seems
to
in some way echo of music by
understanding is that
you
used to play maybe still play the
trumpet
does music
inform
or
act as a compliment to
any of your thinking around physics or
inside of physics well i live in
manhattan where playing the trumpet is
impossible
because
all of a sudden you have everyone within
50 feet of you complaining about your
trumpet playing and so i had to give up
playing the trumpet unfortunately that's
a sacrifice of living in manhattan
but you see there's a joke the joke is
that you put four mathematicians
together and what do you get a string
quartet
einstein played the violin many great
physicists were also violinists because
there's a certain order
out of the chaos comes something
beautiful and to a physicist what is
beauty
beauty to a physicist is symmetry
there's a symmetry in music
for example the simplest cemetery is a
rubber ball you rotate the ball and it
remains the same
why is a kaleidoscope beautiful a
kaleidoscope is beautiful because you
rotate it and it turns into itself
why is an ice crystal beautiful because
you rotate an ice crystal by 60 degrees
and it rotates into itself so that's
what beauty is that if i rearrange the
components of an object it remains the
same
now you can apply that to music and you
can apply that to physics when you apply
that to physics it means that i have an
equation
i rotate its components in a certain
precise way and it rotates into itself
that's called symmetry now the ultimate
symmetry would take the universe just
like the prongs of an ice crystal
rotate all the prongs so that the
universe rotates into itself
that is string theory string theory is
the only theory that has a symmetry
called supersymmetry that if you rotate
all the particles of a vibrating string
it rotates into itself
just like a kaleidoscope just like a an
ice crystal rotates into itself that is
beautiful it's so beautiful in fact that
if einstein had never been born i repeat
if einstein had never been born we would
have discovered
gravity theory anyway as the lowest
octave of the string
the lowest octave of string theory
is relativity this is amazing i mean
think about it if einstein ever never
been born we would have discovered
general relativity anyway as nothing but
the lowest set of music musical notes on
a vibrating string but string theory of
course goes farther it goes beyond that
to the next octave
where we have new forces new particles
emerging and we think that's where dark
matter comes in
dark matter being this thing that that
holds the galaxy together
and i have a challenge for young people
out there for you young people out there
listening to this interview
if you ever discover the god equation
and figure out the mystery of dark
matter
then i'll give you a word of advice what
should you do
first of all
tell me first
tell me first and we'll split the paper
we'll split the nobel prize and we'll
both be considered the next einstein
i like it all right so everybody take
note out there
as you're working on this
i would love to ask you
about
your
decision and maybe it was a set of
decisions or maybe it came about
in in some emergent way organically to
to really be public facing and to
teach and explain
science physics these concepts that
might otherwise not enter
the
sort of awareness of the general public
and i had read an interview with you
where you mentioned a name and i don't
know how to pronounce this last name is
it george gamal g-a-m-o-w gamo
gamo
who
i suppose now it seems is recognized as
one of the great cosmologists of the
last hundred years but could you speak
to if it's still the case why you think
he probably didn't win the nobel prize
well
the
big bang was a controversial theory for
many years especially back in the 30s
and 40s
and people wanted proof you know show me
the b what's the proof that there was
this explosion out there
and then george gamoff and his students
had this idea
that if there was a big bang it was very
hot and it exploded
but it cooled down
and we should be able to measure that
temperature even today
it should be the temperature of outer
space
the temperature of outer space
should be the embers the afterglow of
creation itself which is a measurable
quantity well they did the calculation
and they came out with the fact that the
universe today
should be about five degrees above
absolute zero okay which is awfully
close to the real value which is 2.7
degrees kelvin
so you realize that they came awfully
close to calculating the experimental
proof of the big bang itself
unfortunately they did their work so
early
that it would take a few more decades
before we could begin to measure the
temperature of outer space and show that
the radiation of the big bang is still
with us today believe it or not if you
get a transistor radio and you tune it
between frequencies you get the static
the static we've all heard that
aesthetic right
a certain amount of that static comes
from jupiter jupiter actually gives you
a lot of the static on radio and also
the big bang itself this is amazing when
you listen to the static on the radio
you're listening to
genesis
the big bang itself is still
reverberating throughout the universe
the temperature is in the microwave
range
and it is as predicted about 2.7 degrees
above absolute zero in kelvin
and it was george gamoff who had this
brilliant idea which unfortunately he
never won the nobel prize for
but it shows you with the power of the
imagination and george gamma by the way
was also a cartoonist
and he loved to write children's books
in fact that's when a lot of kids first
get interested in cosmology by reading
the books of george gamma and he
illustrated them himself because he was
an amateur cartoonist that was the
impetus for my asking the question
because it seems like
his colleagues judged him somewhat
harshly or some of them for or no i
shouldn't say they judged him harshly
but they believed that his writing of
these children's books
had an adverse effect on his scientific
reputation i suppose much like some felt
carl sagan had sort of sullied himself
by being on television and my
understanding he was denied admission to
the national academy of sciences so
it seems like there's tremendous value
and it's of great service to engage with
the public but at least there used to be
certain
risks as a scientist in doing so have
those risks largely disappeared or how
did you think about making that decision
for yourself well there are definite
risks because i'm a research physicist
i'm not a popularizer as that's not what
i do for a living what i do for a living
is work on string theory
but there was a turning point that
turning point came in the 1990s when the
physics community was backing the
supercollider the supercollider was this
machine outside dallas texas costing
billions of dollars and in the last days
of hearings one congressman asked the
physicist
quote will we find god with your machine
if so i will vote for it
well the poor guy didn't know what to
say so he basically said
i'm gonna find the higgs boson
well you could hear the jaws hit the
floor of the united states congress
billions of dollars for another goddamn
subatomic particle
well the boat was taken
and it was cancelled and since then we
physicists have racked our brains
saying to ourselves what should we have
said the next time someone asks you are
we going to find god with your machine
if so i will vote for him
well i would have said this
i would have said god
by whatever signs or symbols you ascribe
to the deity this machine the super
collider will take us as humanly
possible to his greatest achievement
genesis
this is a genesis machine
it will recreate on a small scale the
greatest event in the history of the
universe
it's birth
unfortunately we said higgs boson and
she was cancelled but the moral of the
story is
that unless you engage the public
they're not going to give you tax money
to do your research see during the cold
war we physicists had to say just one
word to the united states congress to
get our next atom smasher
all we have to do is say russia
and then congress will whip out the
checkbook and say how much
well those days are gone
we physicists have to sing for our
supper now
we can't just go to congress and assume
they're going to fund our next atom
smasher i mean come on give me a break
it's the european union which built the
large hadron collider and we were more
or less bystanders as the europeans took
the lead in physics so the mecca the the
vatican of physics is now in geneva
switzerland not in dallas texas because
we didn't know how to answer that
question will we find god with your
machine
but this
there's another reason why i got
interested in popularizing science
when i was eight years old as i
mentioned i was fascinated by this book
that einstein couldn't finish so i went
to the library because i knew there was
going to be lots of stuff in that book
things about the fourth dimension
about anti-matter
about wormholes and higher dimensions i
went to the library and i found
nothing
absolutely
nothing
yeah a few primaries about relativity
but nothing about the fourth dimension
nothing about space warps nothing about
hyperdrive nothing
and then i said to myself when i grow up
and i become a theoretical physicist i
want to write books
for myself
for myself as an eight-year-old kid
i want to be able to explain the most
advanced concepts to an eight-year-old
child because that's
how old i was
when i got hooked on physics
and today sure enough eight-year-old
kids email me
and they say that yes my books are the
first introduction they've had the
things that normally they see in a
science fiction movie
but of course it's real science not
science fiction that they hunger for
because once you put down a science
fiction book you realize it's
entertainment i mean give me a break
it's entertainment it's not the universe
at all but when you learn physics you
learn that some of the things that you
find in science fiction are in fact
the cutting edge of physics in fact my
favorite quote from arthur c clarke
is that any sufficiently advanced
technology
is indistinguishable from magic
that is a great quote so i want to i
want to actually use another quote from
a science fiction author to frame a
question and it's this quote which is
often used and abused in all sorts of
ways but it's
from william gibson or more accurately i
think it is actually pulled from
neuromancer but it may be a william
gibson quote which is along the lines of
the future is already here it's just not
evenly distributed
and
just a few more questions left on my
side for the physics of the future you
interviewed 300 or so of the world's top
scientists many of them nobel laureates
about their vision for the next 20 to
100 years in a whole variety of fields
computers robotics biotech space travel
and so on
so here we are in 2021
are there any examples in your mind that
you're particularly excited about of
samples of the future being here right
now
that are going to be more widespread or
known say 10 years 20 years from now
well in that book i anticipated of
course moore's law that computer power
doubles every 18 months and that's an
exponential increase in computer power
not linear see our brain is linear when
we talk about the future we talk
linearly in terms of 5 years 10 years 20
years as if it's a straight line but if
it's exponential it could blow up
it could just blow up and that's what's
happening in my books when i write about
these things many people say to me oh
come on give me a break
this is not going to happen i mean this
is just science fiction well bingo a few
years later it happens and then people
come up to me and they say how did you
do that how did you do that
and it's actually rather simple i
interview the people who are working on
these technologies they're well aware of
moore's law
and as a consequence their time frame is
much different from the average person's
time frame look at the genome project
when the genome project was first
proposed scientists could only sequence
maybe one gene at a time it was painful
one gene at a time and the idea of
sequencing three billion base pairs was
just out of the question in fact i gave
a talk in frankfurt germany once i'll
still remember that a scientist stood up
and said your predictions are all wrong
there's no way the human genome
completely sequenced by 2020 come on
it's not going to happen and he just
ranted and raved because he said i
sequence these genes i know how long it
takes to sequence one gene well guess
what even before 2020 we sequence the
entire genome and now you can do it for
a few hundred bucks and who would have
thought because our brain is linear it
is not exponential but what drives a lot
of these technologies is computer power
which obeys moore's law which is
exponential if we look back this is
going to come back to science instead of
science fiction but right now for fun i
am reading a bunch of heinlein because i
haven't done i haven't read any robert
heinlein in a long time i'm reading time
enough for love
and lazarus long is one of the main
characters as he is in many of
heinlein's novels
and it's incredible for when this book
was written
how
prescient in some ways he was with
respect to technology but
there are a couple of misses they're
still using pens and paper for just
about everything so i think maybe 20 30
years ago people would have predicted
flying cars we don't have flying cars
but
perhaps they wouldn't have seen
the internet and
drones and certainly some of the medical
technologies and advances in
neuroscience
are there any particular predictions or
trends that you would
like to
or could mention that you think are sort
of paving the way for an exciting future
in the next
five to ten or even 20 years but not a
thousand years a lot of the
breakthroughs are going to be happening
with the human brain
the human brain is a was a black box for
generations and generations we didn't
know what the hell was happening in the
brain we knew it was important but it
was just magic the way the brain did
things now of course we're picking apart
the brain with mri machines we can
actually extract images
if you think about a person's face we
can actually extract that image out of
the living brain using mri machines
which is incredible in fact memories
memories can now be taken from the brain
the brain of mice let's be fair about it
but now the brain of monkeys we can
actually take memories simple memories
and put them on the internet
so that other monkeys can enjoy these
memories next will be alzheimer's
patients alzheimer's patients will have
a memory chip so that when you push a
button then memories come flooding into
their mind reminding them of who they
are where they live so they don't wander
the streets endlessly unaware of who
they are and where they're going
and so that is going to be this huge
process by which we create brain net
brain net is the future of the internet
the internet is digital but why does it
have to be digital it's so clumsy why
can't it be neural because that's how
the brain works
and so we're going to have brain net
where memories emotions feelings are
sent on the internet and think about
that what is television what are the
movies it's nothing but a
two-dimensional flat screen with sound
that's it
how primitive
in the future we'll have the internet of
emotions and feelings so that we'll send
feelings on the internet and who wants
to see a movie anymore where you can't
feel what the actors and actresses are
feeling
and so think of teenagers a teenagers
will love it because they put a happy
face at the end of every sentence in the
future the dispute the memory the
sensation after the end of every
sentence so this will change the way
humans interact with each other and it
also means that we'll be able to feel
the suffering of other people when you
read that certain people are suffering
we say to ourselves oh come on give me a
break yeah yeah yeah sure sure
but if you could really feel what
they're feeling you could begin to
realize that some people's sufferings
are are genuine not fake at all so we'll
be able to put ourselves in other
people's shoes
so in the same way that the invention of
the telephone
opened up human interactions on a new
scale
the internet of course made it
numerically possible to communicate
around the world but now we'll be able
to dream about feelings and emotions and
this will replace the movies it'll
replace television
it will be the way humans communicate
with each other in the future not
digitally but with neurons
what a future it will be
dr cocky you've been so generous with
your time your latest bestseller and you
have many bestsellers your latest is the
god equation the subtitle is the quest
for a theory of everything
is that where you would suggest people
start you have certainly a spectrum of
books that you've published you do a lot
of work in many different areas and many
different types of media would you
suggest people start with the god
equation is there another book of yours
you'd pair with it well it depends on
which way you want to go the guide
equation will be a very good
introduction to what i do for a living
and that is the theory of everything
which is the crowning achievement once
we get it of 2000 years of science but
if you're interested in science fiction
you can get a copy of my book physics of
the impossible where i break down time
travel ray guns flying cars everything
you see on the silver screen i break
down in physics of the impossible but if
you are interested in the quantum
applications of all this get a copy of
my book parallel worlds where i talk
about what the quantum means and how
that's going to how it already is
changing the way we view the universe
einstein and newton were wrong about
this the universe really is
probabilistic which means that electrons
can be two places at the same time which
means that maybe people can also be two
places at the same time so that's my
book parallel worlds
but just go to the internet my internet
website is mkaku.org
mkaku
and on facebook i have about four and a
half million fans on facebook wonderful
we will link to all of those certainly
people can find you at mkaku.org
on facebook instagram twitter they can
find you michio kaku easy to find and
we'll link to all of those at tim dot
blog forward slash podcast in the show
notes for everyone
is there anything else before we wrap up
that you would like to
say to my audience any closing comments
any requests that you would like to make
of listeners or anything at all
uh no i think pretty much we've covered
everything by the way my favorite
einstein quote is that if a theory
cannot be explained to a child
then the theory is probably worthless
meaning that all great theories are
based on simple
principles which are pictorial
principles that even a child can
visualize
newton's laws can be summarized by
billiard balls bumping into each other
einstein used clocks and meter sticks to
illustrate his principles
general relativity can be explained in
terms of bed sheets
and so we realize that if a child can
understand it it's because it is
explained pictorially
and because it's based on principles
rather than memorization of details
which you're going to forget anyway that
is a great place to to wrap up and a
great place to end and i think you do an
excellent job of not just popularizing
science but taking complex subjects
and reducing them to principles and
painting pictures in a way that enable
people to understand so i thank you
for your work and i also thank you for
the time this has been incredible fun so
thank you very much yep and my other
motto is if it ain't fun don't do it
that's a great pairing that is an
exceptional pairing thank you so much dr
cocco i really appreciate it okay my
pleasure
hey guys this is tim again just one more
thing before you take off and that is
five bullet friday but you enjoy getting
a short email from me every friday that
provides a little fun before the weekend
between one and a half and two million
people subscribe to my free newsletter
my super short newsletter called five
bullet friday easy to sign up easy to
cancel it is basically a half page that
i send out every friday to share the
coolest things i've found or discovered
or have started exploring over that week
kind of like my diary of cool things it
often includes articles i'm reading
books i'm reading
albums perhaps gadgets gizmos all sorts
of tech tricks and so on that gets sent
to me by my friends including a lot of
podcast guests and these strange
esoteric things end up in my field and
then i test them and then i share them
with you so if that sounds fun again
it's very short a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend something to think about
if you'd like to try it out just go to
tim dot blog friday type that into your
browser tim dot blog slash friday drop
in your email and you'll get the very
next one thanks for listening
this episode is brought to you by
athletic greens i get asked all the time
what i would take if i could only take
one supplement i've been asked this for
years the answer is invariably ag-1 by
athletic greens i view it as all-in-one
nutritional insurance so you can cover
your bases if you're traveling if you're
just busy you're not sure if your meals
or where they should be it covers your
bases i've recommended it
since the hour body which was god eons
ago 2010 and i did not get paid to do so
with approximately 75 vitamins minerals
and whole foods source ingredients
you'll be hard-pressed to find a more
nutrient-dense formula on the market it
has a multivitamin multi-mineral greens
complex probiotics and prebiotics for
gut health and immunity formula
digestive enzymes and adaptogens
you get the idea it is very very
comprehensive and i do my best of course
to focus on nutrient dense proper meals
but sometimes you're busy sometimes
you're traveling sometimes you just want
to make sure
that you're getting what you need ag-1
makes it easy to get a lot of nutrition
when whole foods aren't readily
available it's also nsf certified for
sport making it safe for competitive
athletes as what's on the label is in
the powder it's the ultimate all-in-one
nutritional supplement bundle in one
easy scoop right now athletic greens is
giving my audience a special offer on
top of their all-in-one formula which is
a free vitamin d supplement and five
free travel packs with your first
subscription purchase many of us are
deficient in vitamin d i found that true
for myself which is usually produced in
our bodies from sun exposure so adding a
vitamin d supplement to your daily
routine is a great option for additional
immune support support your immunity gut
health and energy by visiting
athleticgreens.com
tim you'll receive up to a year's supply
of vitamin d and five free travel packs
with your subscription again that's
athleticgreens.com
tim
this episode is brought to you by
99designs the go-to graphic design
platform from vista that makes it easy
for you to find and work with amazing
designers online i have used them for a
long long time we'll come back to that
long time listeners of this podcast know
just how much attention i pay to details
a lot of details and how obsessively i
approach all elements of my work because
often the small things end up being the
big things whether it's your logo your
business cards even your email templates
think of my newsletters all these visual
elements tell your customers who you are
and what you're about so it's worth
sweating the details i've been using 99
designs for years now to ensure that
many of my creative projects whether big
or small are as cohesive professional
and beautiful as possible most recently
you may have noticed i've been working
with a designer at 99designs to create
distinct illustrations for my podcast
episodes you see them on instagram and
other places i've developed a great
relationship with the designer and i
intend to continue working with her for
a long long time from logos to websites
to packaging and books i've also used
99designs for book designs and all sorts
of illustrations 99designs is the go-to
creative resource to build your brand on
any budget right now my listeners can
get 20 off plus a free 99 upgrade on
their first design contest a contest is
a great way to get started and find the
right designer for long-term work you
can also book a free design consultation
with a brand expert at 99designs.com
tim to receive personalized branding
advice over the phone their hands-on
team has helped thousands of business
owners it's a great way to get the most
out of your experience with 99designs by
vista head to 99designs.com
tim that's 99designs.comtim
for your discount and to sign up for
design consultation today
[Applause]